[Applause]
oh my goodness i have so many questions
for both of you okay
okay so cameron you started selling your
brownie mix when you were five years old
yes okay what gave you the idea
so the reason i started making my
brownie mix is because
every time when me
my dad and my sister would um
make the dry brownie mix that you get in
boxes
it was just really fun to me
and
[Music]
and
it was just really fun
yeah okay so you enjoyed it and it made
you happy
and then
shannon you actually created special
traditions with um both your daughters
um one of your daughters sells beauty
products right
so yes um
i tried to
get both of my daughters um
to become entrepreneurs because i just
felt like it was really important
because growing up
no one told me we could own anything we
were always told go to school
go to work and you know find a job to
retire from when you're 60 65
and then live out your golden years and
travel
but for me um i found that there are
very important lessons in ownership and
i wanted my daughters to
learn those lessons
through being entrepreneurs so some of
the life lessons are
being persistent um working hard being
able to play hard
the reward that comes from putting in
the work um financial literacy
credits so it's a bunch of things and
they're young to understand all the
concepts
but i wanted them to have a strong
foundation
and banner entrepreneur i thought would
give them the tools to get them through
life
i mean that is so
amazing
i love this so much now why baking is
that particularly meaningful to you
growing up my mom's a single mom and she
wasn't a baker she could cook my mom
made wonderful meals but being a single
mom
four kids
bacon just wasn't on her list of things
to do
and i would go to friends house and they
would have like baked goods and cookies
and cakes so that's how i would get my
snacks at friends house so as i got
older one of the things that i wanted to
do with my daughters
was start our own traditions and baking
to me i'm like a math and logistics
guide so numbers work and as long as you
measure things correctly you can't
really mess up bacon so i felt like it
was easy enough for me and my daughters
to start to bake and that'll be our you
know little tradition that we get to do
together so they could say when they get
older oh yeah we baked with our dad all
the time but we had baked goods in the
house all the time and cameron how did
you come up with the recipes
so i came up with the recipes with my
dad
and we baked the cookies about eight
times before
we
got the perfect recipe in fact um i have
some right here
this is going to go wow
um
and i was wondering if um you would tell
me where do you see this business going
you're you started at five you're eight
what is your future and and dreams where
would you like to take this
um
so maybe one day
um
maybe i'm thinking maybe i could act in
a movie oh
i don't see that one coming
yeah that was that's that's breaking
news to me
that is breaking news to me
well let me tell you something
as someone who talks to my daughter
about
um
you know being an actor or being in the
business
i think
what's really important
because i learned business skills too
when i was young and how to be a
professional and it served me really
well
but what you really need is someone
looking after you
and taking care of you and keeping those
boundaries up and keeping you straight
and you're a really good dad so i think
that
wherever these dreams go
you cameron's going to be in really safe
hands with you shannon you're such a
good dad and i think a real example to
us all it was really eye-opening to hear
your reasonings behind what you're doing
with your daughters and
cameron isn't it true you get straight
a's
i
can i please give a quick review of your
cookie
yeah
oh my gosh
it is so buttery
and
moist and chocolatey
but
it's also
matter it it's crunchy
but then
it also feels um
moist
and it's like and it's it's everything
that you want in a cookie your product
is just incredible
thank you
oh my god i and i i hate the whole thing
so there you go it is so good your
product is so wonderful and if it's okay
i have a little surprise for you we
wanted to give you a customized
barrymore show
stand mixer
in our custom yellow color
so that you could think of us
when you're making this and also i just
want to throw you a thousand dollars to
see how
[Applause]
you and your father
want to use it for your business because
i asked if you guys are going to grow
you're going to need more hands and more
help so i just wanted to give you that
to spend it where you see fit and
congratulations on your beautiful family
[Music]